how's it goin everybody it's Warren and
last week Marvel and Disney showed some
footage of Avengers in game to the press
in Burbank California they showed them
two scenes and one scene was actually
given to us a couple of days ago when
Marvel released their special look at
Avengers in game the other scene that
was shown to them was of the beginning
of the movie now not too much was really
known about this scene when the
description of it came out because of
course the press couldn't talk about it
but now more information has come to
light about this scene including more
information about the message that Tony
sent to pepper I'll talk about it and
break it all down in this video if
you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe
I do monthly giveaways right now giving
away a life-sized Infinity Gauntlet and
a painting of Thanos by Globe I bow like
to enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain so as I said we
have more information about the opening
scene for Avengers endgame according to
GameSpot calm it starts off by showing
the Marvel logo and then it cuts to Tony
and nebula playing paper football you
know paper football the game that you
would play in elementary school where
you would fold up a piece of paper into
a triangle and then flick it at a
goalpost made by the other person's
hands that one as the scene starts off
we hear dear mr. fantasy in the
background
no doubtedly from a mixtape that quill
has some previous reports we know that
Tony and nebula actually bond over play
in this game
Tony has recovered from his wounds from
his fight with feyo's with the help of
nebula and Tony's message to pepper we
actually learned that nebula is pretty
good at healing in Tony's message he
says that despite getting some
infections in his wounds from the Battle
of fan os-- he's quickly recovering
thanks to nebulas health we've also
learned from Tony's message to pepper
that him and nebula have actually
managed to partially repair the ship in
his message he says that they've been
working hard to repair the ship in an
attempt to make it back home he says
that the fuel cells were damaged at some
point but they've managed to fix things
up well enough to get around two days of
flight time from the benitar but then he
goes on to say that they're light-years
from the nearest 7-eleven and he's not
sure how much that will help we then go
on to find out just how much time has
passed between the events of Avengers
infinity war and the events of Avengers
endgame in Tony's message to pepper
he specifically says that him and nebula
have been stranded in space for 22 days
but in the final part of Toni's message
to pepper he says that despite repairing
the ship he still expects that he's
going to die Tony says that even though
his wounds are healing and they've
managed to repair the ship partially the
ship is still in very poor condition and
he's about to run out of oxygen this is
a scene that we partially saw with the
very first teaser trailer for Avengers
in game Tony says that he's ran out of
food and water and that oxygen is going
to run out the next morning he ends his
message with a sad expectation that he
is going to die when I drift off I will
dream about him so I see
[Music]
he says that when he drifts off into
death he'll think of pepper it's always
been pepper and that's what we've
learned about the message that Tony
sends to pepper from the footage that
was shown by Marvel and Disney to the
press we know from the trailers that
Tony Stark and nebula do make it back to
earth so let me know how you think
they'd get back to earth and what you
think about this scene let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below and
again don't forget to subscribe comment
and like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date with
everything relating to Avengers and game
and Marvel as always thank you all so
much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]